[Music]
if you don't live in dc you probably
haven't heard the name but tim unis is a
republican event planner in washington
for 25 years he helped organize
appearances for senator bob dole and his
wife senator elizabeth dole he was close
to the family when bob dole died last
week eunice was the obvious choice to
manage the funeral and the memorial
service and he would have done that if
mitch mcconnell hadn't gotten personally
involved now technically mitch mcconnell
is the republican leader of the united
states senate but in real life and
everyone in washington knows this on the
issues that matter
mitch mcconnell is an instrument of the
left
mcconnell knew that tim eunice had
helped organize donald trump's political
rally in washington this january there's
nothing illegal or immoral about doing
that if anything is constitutionally
protected behavior it's organizing a
political rally it's why we have the
bill of rights
but the partisan lunatics on the january
6 committee don't acknowledge the bill
of rights and they objected to this and
then mitch mcconnell aggressively took
their side as he has from the very
beginning
so mcconnell then convinced the dole
family to cancel tim eunice's contract
and disinvite him from the funeral then
mcconnell made sure the story made the
new york times and when he did that he
knew perfectly well that a piece like
this would completely destroy tim
younis's life which unfortunately it
definitely will it will mean no more
corporate clients no more business no
more income for tim eunice
so even by mitch mcconnell's usual
standards of viciousness and in
washington he's known as the nasty old
nastiest old woman in town
this was an incredibly cruel thing to do
it was crushing the weak on behalf of
the strong and for no real reason simply
because he could and doesn't like trump
now this is hardly the first time mitch
mcconnell has done something vicious
like this but we thought that going
forward we would start telling you about
it because why wouldn't we